ambiance festive et décalée à guyancourt
pour la fête de l'enfance
placée cette année sur le thème de
l'entr'aide du respect de l'autre et de
l'environnement pour l'occasion un
carrousel à la gloire des légumineuses
de toutes les formes et de toutes les
couleurs divertit et du que les enfants
les luttes c'est sensibiliser bas à
l'alimentation à des légumes qui ne
connaissent plus
l'artichaut par exemple voilà c'est
puisque c'est que l'artichaut et puis
voilà en étant ludique parce que c'est
notre rôle de saltimbanques une après
midi
rythmé par des animations pédagogiques
et recyclables voilà c'est du carton
c'est bien qu'est ce que tu as fait chez
toi j'ai péché briques de lait ça ça se
recycler pas la fête de l'enfance à
guyancourt ce sont aussi des animaux or
noir
autant d'intervenants venus sensibiliser
petits et grands
les abeilles sont le principal un sac
polémique pollinisateurs donc les
informer pour pour leur apprendre à ne
plus tuer les abeilles à deux pas
l'étape et quand il les voit une piqûre
de rappel nécessaire pour préserver la
biodiversité